computer-aided software has made  architecture so amazing but what it  hasn't done is taken back the freedom of  art now with morphology Trace you can  simply grab an iPad grab the apple  pencil pair them together with the  morfolio trace app and you can start  bringing your creativity back to life  are you able to Overlay some amazing  architectural CAD drawings directly from  PDF into the app you can also go ahead  and start overlaying some incredible  hand-drawn watercolored landscape plans  not only do you have 100 pencils in one  and all sorts of watercolor pencils at  your disposal you can quickly and  rapidly fill areas paste stencils of  trees rocks landscaping and all things  in between but you can also Redline  annotate your entire project exactly the  way you want it erase it and make sure  it's perfect every single time  foreign